jour 6 de la visite en n2 justin trudeau
et le premier ministre est accueillie
officiellement au palais présidentiel à
première vue difficile de constater des
signes de tension avec son homologue
narendra modi un baume sur un voyage qui
a des radiers notamment en raison de la
question séparatistes sic qui a pris
beaucoup de place en n c'est un sujet
sensible
narendra modi a déclaré qu'on ne peut
pas tolérer ce qui conteste la
souveraineté et l'unité de nos pays sur
le libéral au congrès et cette question
a aussi créé des remous au québec c'est
que dans un compte rendu
le gouvernement du pendjab rapporte que
justin trudeau a dit dans une rencontre
avoir combattu toute sa vie
les dangers de violences possibles
associé au mouvement séparatiste du
québec justin trudeau n'avait pas besoin
d'une autre controverse
le rapport est entièrement faux je n'ai
pas dit ça au contraire je suis et j'ai
toujours été très fier du fait que le
canada et le québec ont des leçons à
partager avec le monde sur le pluralisme
la diversité les différents points de
vue sans avoir recours à aucune violence
un point de presse finale
l'occasion de dresser un bilan justin
trudeau fait fi de toutes les critiques
ça a été extrêmement positif
particulièrement au niveau des affaires
où on a pu annoncer un milliard de
dollars en investissements au canada et
en inde est aussi presque 6000 nouveaux
emplois au canada qui vont être créés il
ne donne aucun exemple de ce qu'il
aurait pu faire autrement
en tout cas pas s'habiller différemment
que je sois en tenue traditionnelle ou
en complet et va sans cravate et ça a
été un voyage où les gens ont eu des
réactions extrêmement positif
extrêmement positif deux mots que justin
trudeau a répété souvent mais qui sont
loin de refléter les perceptions tant à
l'échelle nationale qu'internationale
si son voyage s'achève et les risques
d'en entendre parler à son retour en
chambre lundi et pendant encore
longtemps ici madeleine gay m'aurait
radio canada new delhi